mark zuckerberg is fighting tooth and
nail for the metaverse but it's not
going well the value of his company just
fell by 230 billion dollars in a single
day and that's largely because of
increased competition from other big
tech companies everyone wants to
capitalize on the next era of the
internet but no one has put more
pressure on zuck than apple this might
surprise you because most people
associate the metaverse with virtual
reality and apple hasn't released a vr
headset yet but apple has three advanced
business strategies that will
essentially make it impossible for
zuckerberg to win in the long term if
technology trends continue to progress
exponentially trillions of dollars will
be up for grabs as we shift to an
increasingly connected world everyone is
going to want a piece so let's dig into
how apple plans to stay on top
virtual reality will clearly be an
important part of the metaverse just
look at the success of vr chat which
recently hit an all-time high of 40 000
concurrent users now that's still small
by the standards of big tech but with
more and more people buying vr headsets
each year the technology is clearly here
to stay but apple has taken a peculiar
stance on virtual reality even though 7
million people bought oculus headsets
last year over 230 million people bought
iphones and these new iphones come with
some key pieces of hardware that make it
clear that apple thinks augmented
reality and not virtual reality is the
future now to be clear here apple has
been dabbling in virtual and augmented
reality for decades and even showcased a
prototype headset all the way back in
1987 but apple is an incredibly
secretive company and they don't
typically announce new products until
they're ready to go when steve jobs
announced the original iphone it shipped
just six months later but even though
apple hasn't said anything publicly
about their augmented reality project
there is a good amount of information
out there about it if you look close
enough see back in 2015 a financial
analyst published a report claiming that
apple had quietly built a small team to
explore the augmented reality field
google glass had just launched a few
years earlier and ran into a number of
adoption issues people felt like they
were being spied on since the headset
had a camera on it and in general the
user experience was pretty awkward it's
very much one of these where they're
clearly not looking in front of you
they're reading something like
something's hovering up above your head
and you're like what are you looking at
over me apple knew that launching a
half-baked product would tarnish the
brand they had spent decades building so
they took their time with the project
and started laying a foundation for a
truly revolutionary product in order to
build this team apple hired hundreds of
engineers and product designers to focus
on augmented reality full-time they also
started buying up any company that had
relevant expertise apple's first
purchase was prime sense a company that
had figured out how to track body
movements and use them to control
computers next they bought a company
that could quickly create augmented
reality scenarios the tech was still
rough around the edges but has improved
steadily over the past few years then
apple acquired three separate companies
that were working on facial capture and
analysis this technology not only
enabled face id but also went on to
power the animoji system that's
available on newer iphones animoji might
look primitive compared to the
remarkably realistic animated faces we
see in big budget hollywood movies but
it's an important stepping stone to
enabling emotive communication in the
metaverse with facial recognition
quickly becoming a solved problem apple
has moved on to buying companies focused
more directly on augmented and virtual
reality in 2017 they bought vrvana which
had been working on a mixed reality
headset called totem and then one year
later they bought akonia holographics
which was focused on making lenses for
ar glasses but these acquisitions aren't
the only way to track apple's progress
in augmented reality they also have a
ton of publicly available patent filings
and these actually date back even
further in 2008 apple patented four
different prototypes for head-mounted
displays this was years before oculus
even started and it's crazy to think
about it but facebook didn't even have a
mobile app back then these patents look
pretty basic by today's standards but
they show that apple was exploring every
possibility there was even one that
showed an iphone slotted in directly in
front of the user's eyes much like
google cardboard and gear vr would do
years later and more recently apple
patented a finger-mounted device that
will allow users to control virtual
content using natural hand movements so
apple is clearly spending a ton of time
and effort on research and development
here but people often overlook what
apple is doing right in front of our
noses see apple might be delaying the
launch of a real pair of ar glasses but
they aren't holding back on adding those
innovations to their current products
every year the iphone the ipad and the
apple watch become slightly more
powerful and it can be easy as a
consumer to miss what's really going on
apple has been slowly shrinking every
piece of technology and including more
sensors in each iteration for example
lidar sensors are extremely valuable
when you're trying to map an environment
in augmented reality and apple has been
able to get this technology in the hands
of hundreds of millions of people it
started with the top tier ipad but now
lidar ships with each new iphone pro
these phone-enabled experiences are
still far cry from the immersive worlds
that zuckerberg has promised but apple
has an army of independent app
developers who are eager to capitalize
on every new piece of technology apple
deploys this wouldn't be such a problem
for zuck if apple products weren't so
popular see globally only about 20
percent of people carry iphones but
among young adults in america apple's
market share is 70
so when developers want to release the
next big app they look to apple
immediately instagram is a perfect
example here they wanted to capture that
young american market so they went a
full two years without an android app at
all this is exactly what apple wants to
have happen and if this strategy works
the metaverse will just slowly develop
on top of apple products and they will
essentially win by default but this
strategy is a double-edged sword that
could wind up killing the metaverse
before it even gets started and to
understand why we have to look at this
one simple button it's the app store
purchase button and if you've ever used
an iphone you're probably very familiar
with it but behind this simple design
lies one of the most controversial
business models in history it wasn't
controversial at launch though when
steve jobs first introduced the app
store to the public in 2008 the audience
cheered there is no charge for free apps
at all there's no charge to the user it
seemed like an amazing deal after all
there was no way for developers to load
custom software onto iphones at the time
and the app store had no hosting fees no
marketing fees and no credit card
processing fees but the next decade
would change everything smartphones
became ubiquitous and every business
needed to launch an iphone app and fast
the app store worked perfectly for
companies with advertising based
business models in 2018 facebook and
google controlled eight of the top 10
smartphone apps in the us and because
these apps were free to download apple
didn't get a cut of the revenue they
generated from advertising but things
are changing increasingly people are
willing to pay for services that they
love and they don't want to be
constantly advertised to just look at
fortnite the game is wildly successful
and often pointed to as an excellent
bridge to the metaverse what started
exclusively as a competitive shooter is
now regularly hosting concerts in a few
years i wouldn't be surprised if you can
do a whole lot more there's only one
thing standing in the way though apple's
app store fees even though games like
fortnite are free to download apple
still takes a 30 cut of in-app purchases
this might have seemed reasonable in
2008 when the iphone was still brand new
but when developers have the option of
going direct and paying just three
percent to a service like stripe 30
seems exorbitant and here's the crazy
thing apple actually admitted that they
couldn't possibly expect to hold on to
their precious 30 cut forever in 2011 an
apple executive wrote an email
suggesting that apple should consider
lowering the fee once they started
making over 1 billion dollars per year
well that never happened and apple made
85 billion dollars from the app store
last year way beyond that proposed cap
so why does this matter and how does it
affect zuckerberg well we have to
clarify our definition of the metaverse
a bit here see i don't think it's fair
to just throw on a vr headset and say
that you're in the metaverse that's cool
and all but it's not quite what people
mean by the term it's best to throw out
the buzzwords and just ask the question
what will the internet look like in 10
years will vr be a part of it almost
certainly but there are going to be a
ton of other important developments the
type of content that can be streamed
will change thanks to faster wireless
connectivity more real-world data will
be represented virtually enabling the
type of ar experiences that apple is
working on and entire economies will
develop online this last part is really
critical we're already seeing some of
this happen with crypto communities and
game development is increasingly funded
by the sale of virtual goods as soon as
people can start trading digital items
and moving them from one virtual world
to another markets for these items
should flourish but apple wants to take
a 30 cut of every transaction that
happens on an ios device and that could
wind up crushing innovation when apple
launched the app store they promoted it
with an amazing ad campaign called
there's an app for that it was
remarkably catchy and introduced the
world to the idea of apps as friendly
and helpful tools that they could easily
download one big benefit of the app
store was that every piece of software
was reviewed by apple now will there be
limitations of course there are going to
be some apps that we're not going to
distribute porn malicious apps apps that
invade your privacy so there will be
some apps that we're going to say no to
that safety guarantee from apple was a
huge boon to user adoption everyone from
children to grandparents felt
comfortable downloading and using apps
but apple didn't just restrict malicious
apps they also put up barriers to
competition steve jobs made this crystal
clear in an email to his team when he
wrote i think this is all pretty simple
ibooks is going to be the only bookstore
on ios devices adoption of the metaverse
will most likely be driven by today's
young adults and 70 of them are
currently using iphones if people end up
wanting to use their iphones and apple
watches to interact with the metaverse
zuckerberg is going to have to fork over
30 of his profits apple is pressuring
zuckerberg on two fronts right now
they're leveraging their top-tier
product development teams to build
competitive ar hardware and then
standing strong on their app store fees
to ensure they get a cut of mobile
revenue going forward but there's
actually one more reason why apple is in
such a strong position and to understand
it we have to go back nearly 40 years in
history
it was 1983 and the computing revolution
was well underway personal computers
were making their way into the homes of
everyday people and technology was
beginning to transform every aspect of
american life apple was still a small
company back then and steve jobs needed
to recruit as many talented people as
possible so he traveled to aspen
colorado and gave a speech at the
international design conference in his
speech he outlined a remarkably
prophetic vision for the future of
technology apple's strategy is really
simple
what we want to do is we want to put an
incredibly great computer in a book that
you can carry around with you that you
can learn how to use in 20 minutes
that's what we want to do we want to do
it this decade and we really want to do
it with a radio link in it so you don't
have to hook up to anything you're in
communication with all these larger
databases and other computers the device
he was describing sounds a lot like an
ipad to me but here's the thing jobs
wanted to ship this device by 1990 but
the ipad didn't launch until 2010 so he
was off by 20 years even so the ipad
wound up becoming a massively successful
product and there's an important lesson
here even when technology entrepreneurs
can predict the future accurately they
often get the timing wrong that's okay
though as long as the technology does
arrive eventually they'll be remembered
as visionaries so here's the key
question can zuckerberg deliver on the
vision he's mapped out within a
reasonable amount of time apple was
still a small company back in 1983.
metta has 58 000 employees zuckerberg is
clearly going to be duking it out with
apple for the next decade and there's
still the question of how fortnite and
epic games fits into all of this the
story of how fortnite became so massive
is really fascinating and you can learn
all about it by watching this video next
thanks a lot